that's right Ma you did it defensively
you didn't play making wires you did
some other ways too but ultimately what
was the deciding factor and how you guys
were able to come back and get this win
uh we started playing with some harder
intensity that was first that first
quarter and a half they punched us and
we were down 20 and take a real one to
talk when you're down 20. and I was able
to get my guys going and then they
started doing what they doing I could do
what I do what got you going you were
going at him in that second quarter what
got you through that level
it's a good hard foul and CJ started
talking you know you don't start talking
play play the game and just enjoy what
y'all were doing they were playing a
good game and he started talking and
that's my type of game I like that and
that's that's what I do I grew up in
Saginaw Michigan that's how we play and
so once they won to go there I enjoyed
that so in the song four you pick up
your fourth hour 30 seconds into that
corner what you wanted to say in with
the gross is running hot how are we able
to maintain the Boys At That World coach
trust me trust me to play with those
four fouls and they made the decision to
try to go at me the very next place and
it was a turnover and that changes the
game because all of a sudden you thought
you get my fifth and now you allowing me
to talk again and that was beautiful so
Drake you're the best trash talker in
the league I'm gonna go out there and
say that can you give us a PC version of
something that you were saying over to
the Pelican side tonight yeah I just
told them they weren't cut like that
that's not what they do there's some you
know we're all good guys I'm not acting
like I'm a bad guy but I like to talk
and play that really gets me going and
that's not everybody's game so I
appreciate your time brother good luck
sir thank you